sieben lange wochen haben wir einen
skurrilen einblick in die toxische ehe
von johnny depp und amber heard erhalten
heute heißt es nun endlich schuldig oder
unschuldig hat johnny depp seine ex
amber heard misshandelt tja oder hat sie
vielleicht doch seine karriere zerstört
es ist der zivilprozess des jahres in
den usa und es geht um sehr viel geld 50
millionen dollar will johnny depp für
die zerstörte karriere 100 millionen
will amber für die angeblich erlittene
gewalt in der ehe die große frage ist
jetzt wie entscheiden die geschworenen
wem glaubt die jury es sind die finalen
stunden im prozess oder und johnny depp
gegen amber heard seit wochen läuft das
spektakuläre gerichtsverfahren neben
allerlei intimen und verstörenden
details die bestimmt wurden was vor
allem auch ein kampf um sympathie wem
glaubt die öffentlichkeit dem die jury
glauben wird das könnte sich schon in
wenigen stunden entscheiden in einem
dienstag konnte die jury nach
stundenlanger beratung noch kein urteil
fällen
kurz nach 17 uhr die jury wurde eben
nach hause entlassen das heißt es ist
heute zu keinem gut angekommen man sieht
ja es ist ein wahnsinn ist
medienaufgebot alle haben gehofft dass
es ihm heute das urteil gibt aber das
pensum ist sehr hoch die jury hat 38
seiten an aufgaben die sie durch
sprechen müsste das sind alle ja und
nein antworten sind 38 seiten sie waren
heute auf der seite 4 es gab nämlich
eine frage an die richterin auf der
seite für die dann beantwortet wurde
vergangenen freitag hatten die anwälte
ihre schlussplädoyers gehalten alles
versucht um ein letztes mal
aufzutrumpfen und was macht johnny depp
im anschluss der fliegt erst mal nach
england und tritt gemeinsam mit musiker
jeff beck auf als ob sonst nichts weiter
bei ihm los wäre sollte das etwa der
letzte auftritt seiner karriere werden
werden die geschworenen schuldig
sprechen oder werden sie sich gegen
erwin schreiben
was haben sie verloren durch die
anschuldigungen von es hart
nicht weniger als alles
stütze hier und weiß dass ich keine
karriere mehr haben kann menschen können
nicht mehr mit mir in verbindung
gebracht werden die drohungen und
angriffe die auf sie ertragen müssen
wie die jury auch entscheiden wird eines
ist schon jetzt klar nach dieser
schlammschlacht guintoli depp und amber
heard haider als verlierer nach hause
wir wollten von unserer korrespondentin
caddy pfleger natürlich wissen wann wir
jetzt endlich mit einem urteil der
geschworenen rechnen können
es ist sehr schwierig das einzuschätzen
es sind ja wie gesagt 38 seiten an jury
aufgaben die durchgegangen werden müsste
das sind ja und nein fragen an da muss
bei jeder frage muss die jury sich
einstimmig dafür vereins entscheiden
und das dauert einfach das war heute
waren sie bei der seite 4 erst das heißt
es kann natürlich jetzt so schneller
geht es kann sich aber auch noch
hinziehen und die frage ist natürlich an
das ist die allgemeine meinung ist dass
es darum geht ob um gewalt ob johnny
depp sie geschlagen hat oder fan
geschlagen haben aber in diesem prozess
geht es nämlich gar nicht darum es geht
um freunde und um diesen artikel diese
amber heard in der washington post
geschrieben hat diese ganze
informationen die wir gehört haben die
furchtbaren diese gewaltausbrüche auch
von ein paar hört spielen damit gar
nicht so viel mit rheines geht
eigentlich nur darum um ihre
glaubwürdigkeit zu widerlegen
dieser dieser verleumdung fall das ist
einfach wahnsinnig schwer das zu
beweisen und deswegen kann sich das auf
sehr lange hinziehen nun geht ja auch um
sehr viel geld katie johnny depp hat
emma hört ja auf 50 millionen dollar
verklagt sie verlangt von ihm wiederum
100 millionen dollar wie wahrscheinlich
ist es denn überhaupt dass einer von
beiden diese summe bekommt
also das ist er sehr unwahrscheinlich
ist hat auch er einen symbolischen wert
zum beispiel bei den abschluss bilden
hat die anwältin elaine bradford ist die
anwälte von amber heard gesagt wir
wollen keine 100 millionen das war
einfach nur eine reaktion auf die 50
millionen mwh wir wollen
350.000 dollar und das ist natürlich
schon ein eingeständnis dass man sagt
okay wir geben uns mit 350.000 dollar
zufrieden und für johnny depp braucht
das geld im grunde nicht das ist aber
der verlust den er gemacht hat diese
filmprojekte die er verloren hat durch
eben diesen kommentar der veröffentlicht
wurde aber johnny hat das erreicht was
er wollte er wollte sein seiner
wahrnehmen oder sein bild er sich selbst
wieder herrscht der nutzer gemacht hat
wahnsinnig von diesem prozess gewonnen
als der klare verlierer er der klare
gewinner in der öffentlichen meinung hat
so viele fans so viele unterstützung so
viele leute wollen ihn sehen und er hat
damit im grunde schon gewonnen über
amber heard die im grunde alles verloren
hat sie wird wahrscheinlich nie wieder
arbeiten
alle leute hassen sie also was gerade
auf social media ab nee das ist wahnsinn
man weiß auch bahn gibt sich davon
jemals wieder erholen kann als es geht
kaum weniger um die summe des geldes ist
niedrig um die öffentliche wahrnehmung
johnny depp ganz klar denn die ja
man muss schon sagen es ist bitter was
aus dieser ehe geworden ist wie dieser
prozess verlaufen ist und irgendwo sind
tatsächlich dann auch ja beide verlierer
muss man sagen dankeschön für den moment
in die usa und wir werden das ganze
natürlich beobachten sobald das urteil
fällt sind wir live dabei